Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two David.
Here's a caller who wants more interviews
with loony people.
Do you agree with them?
Take a listen.
Speaker 7: Hey, David, this is Devin from
Rhode Island.
Yeah, I was wondering if you would go back
to interviewing the loonies, you know, all
the crazy people and delusional people, Godfried
doctors, because.
Watching you handle professionally handle
these people really helps us normal people
who aren't naturally gifted at it, who might
blow up emotionally, who don't know how to
respond to the faulty logic, watching you
interact and and question them and then listen
to their answer and take apart their answer,
or we give them credit when they are right.
Watching you do that really helps us maybe
do a poll and see what other people think.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, I really appreciate
the kind words.
The reason we've gotten away from it is sometimes
the loony people are also really annoying
to schedule interviews with like as in as
loony as they are on camera.
They're just as loony in the management of
their personal calendar.
And to be perfectly frank, I got a little
bored with it because it's like, yeah, how
most of us know that these people exist.
And I find that it's better to critique their
views without them.
Right.
They're screaming and going nuts.
It's sometimes much more productive that way.
But I'm open to doing more of the loony interviews
if people are really interested in that.
It just I was starting to get a little bored
with it.
And my sense was the audience maybe didn't
care for it that much, but I'm certainly willing
to look at that.
On today's Bonas show, states that ended federal
unemployment benefits saw no clear job gains
despite what right wingers were claiming would
happen.
California is going to launch the nation's
largest free student lunch program, but how
can they afford it with their huge budget
surplus?
That's exactly how.
And a US judge has upheld Indiana University's
vaccine requirement, which applies in the
fall to students, faculty and staff.
We will talk about why and we will talk about
what we are likely to see in other challenges
against college vaccine requirements.
All of that and even more on today's bonus
show.
Sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom.
We will see you there or tomorrow.